今天台灣股市又下跌了
很多人想要知道說
為什麼台幣狂升 外資大買
為何46000過不了關
為什麼會這樣子
我今天獨家告訴你
如果我說就是結算的關係呢
那結算後何去何從
第二個 AI巨頭狂發債
為什麼狂發債會排擠股市資金
兩方面
從債市跟股市的關係
我獨家告訴大家
哲哲是總體經濟的專家
相信哲哲
我會講得非常之清楚
第三個 明天結算過後台股怎麼走
明天結算日 台股定生死
今天獨家跟大家報告
甚至我們今天股票
有股票很強
拉上漲停了
這又代表什麼意義
可是被動元件看起來現在非常的弱
這些代表什麼意義
今天獨家的解讀一切的飆股
今天台股開高走低
很多股票通通被壓回
最後跌了548點
收跌在45308點
很多人都想知道
為什麼會開高走低
但是投資長的股票
還是照樣狂噴猛噴
昨天慘遭跌停的精材
今天開盤沒多久就攻上漲停
還有環球晶
也是開盤不到20分鐘就亮燈漲停
真的太厲害了
中美晶也一度大漲超過4%
但是投資朋友們一定很好奇
今天台股到底為什麼會開高走低
明天台指期結算會如何影響台股
你想知道投資長是怎麼看的嗎
你手上還沒有飆股嗎
接下來就交給我們經濟日報選股冠軍
單季188%的紀錄保持者
同時也是全台灣唯一百萬粉絲
最受歡迎的分析師
郭哲榮投資長 投資長好
Lily 各位投資朋友大家好
Lily今天很有朝氣
我跟大家講
台灣股市如果能跟你一樣有朝氣就好
可是不用緊張
明天過後就有朝氣了 是
為什麼這樣說
因為其實這就是結算
我給大家結論 這就是結算
你去想一個分析師
如果一個分析師跟你講說
今天會一路走低 要怎麼辦
我有預告到 我是真的有預告到
我那時候不是說當沖順勢盤
要嘛一路走高 要嘛一路低 對
其實那你說哲哲
你不是廢話
要嘛就漲 要嘛跌
沒有 有些人邏輯不太好
這個漲跟跌不一樣
走高是這樣子 一路走高
你可能漲上去再跌下去對不對 對
或跌下去再漲上來
所以我是一路走高 一路走低
那不知道等9點半過後就可以了
所以你看今天的期貨走勢
不懂期貨沒關係
重點是期貨會影響台股
你稍微聽我講一下就可以了 好不好
所以我講的是說
其實在這邊他沒有大家想像中複雜
一路走低以後對不對
你看我們在這邊空
45350點空有沒有
大家都在240點出場 為什麼
因為他期貨非常明顯
等我一下
期貨非常之明顯
你看 是不是一路走低 是
很明顯 真的是很明顯
既然是一路的走低
那你應該逢高空
如果今天台灣股市來個U型上漲
你這邊空就錯了
所以他從頭到尾
就是一個結算日的績效
結算日就是在這邊漲很多了
有外資的力量 市場的力量
他就是一路走低
他要壓低結算
就是為了壓低結算
台灣股市彈了7000點
彈了快7000點
39000彈到46000
一下要到新高了
可是你還是要時間來琢磨
就這麼簡單而已
不要想那麼多
你以為天天激情 是不是
你以為天天有八卦
有最新的八卦
陳幸妤八卦 Joeman八卦
沒有這麼多啦 每天就這樣
可是哲哲的節目
永遠有激情
沒有關係
你就繼續看我的節目就好了嘛
我還是會跟你講這個邏輯
所以我們今天期貨怎麼樣
快速講一下
所以今天期貨很簡單
我們就賺240點嘛 很簡單
恭喜我們期貨當沖空單
已經在45110點出場
成功獲利240點
你看 我們在這邊
45350空有沒有看到
你看中午空還來得及 對
早上空應該空更多
獲利240點 是不是
逢高空而已啦
所以你去想想看你要怎樣的分析師
我們今天點點名
你看昨天
我之前也有預告
所以你要了解
期貨我可以預測成功
代表是今天更是怎麼樣
它只是為了結算而已
來 我們看一下
上禮拜有講
來 再來一次
最強EPS都大跌 反彈結束了
有沒有 是不是結束了
好像連兩天不太行
就有點弱勢 不能說不太行
來看一下我們的預告
上禮拜五的時候預告
下禮拜就是一路走高當沖順勢盤
或是一路走低
請助理提醒我
因為最近賺太多
賺了這個4000點以後
就比較少操作了
因為一口氣就賺100%以上 是
70幾萬好像賺到80萬
70幾萬的保證金賺到80幾萬
這個跟大家講
一路走高 一路走低
來 我們來看一下
那個 不好意思
來講一下這個東西
然後我記得還有一段
沒關係 那個助理有另外一段更好
我說9點半過後就知道了
你們聽得懂嗎 是
所以你到9點半過後你就知道
要嘛一路走高 一路走低
那9點半過後就把它踢掉
不是一路走高
9點半以後一直跌
那就知道 那繼續空
逢高空
期貨的世界是這樣子
只有賺錢跟賠錢而已 知道嗎
那我跟大家講
那今天很多人說
哲哲 救救國巨
我早就跟你講國巨要做價差
你們不理我 是不是
國巨要做價差 等一下
來看一下
國巨要做價差 你們不理我
預告在前了
畫面轉過來一下 還在跑
永豐這個軟體
20年前的軟體 不太行
雖然我常用 來
國巨今天最低574
我覺得不錯啊
我覺得如果跌到570
甚至550以下我會再買
哲哲 國巨會不會打第二隻腳
我跟你說
我並不會認為他會打第二隻腳
會破底
我覺得破底機率很低
第一個為什麼
台灣股市要再破底的機率很低
你聽得懂嗎
我們在39000
台灣股市要破底的機率
你看國巨算彈很低了
我甚至覺得明天你還沒進場國巨
你可以大膽進場
可是你不是我的會員
我不會跟你講點位
你要不要參加我們這個
明天就截止的逆轉188的專案
你自己參考好不好
你自己參考
股市 好不好
就像我們人生一樣
我昨天有跟大家講
怎麼樣
留一點給人家賺
我說為什麼現在很多人
網紅被爆
因為你讓人家委屈
男生讓女生委屈
或女生讓男生委屈
是不是
之前還有什麼Andy老師對不對 對
很多人說 哲哲你不公平
替女生講話
沒有 我也替男生講話
都有 好不好
Andy老師或者是
Joeman的事件被爆
或者是陳幸妤的事件
跟趙建銘的事件
為什麼被爆
你有沒有發現到很簡單
心委屈了 被辜負了
被分手一番不高興了
你錢也委屈了
如果Andy
錢沒有被人家全部拿走
一文都不值的情況之下
他會告人家嗎
所以不要讓對方心委屈
感情世界一定有心委屈
不然怎麼會分手
可是錢不要讓人家委屈
就不會亂爆了
這個也是一樣
所以不要什麼好處都一定要拿到
也是一樣
國巨也是一樣
國巨比方說一個好處
直通到1200
不可能 我早就跟你講
1200不可能的
我甚至說800元以上
都有壓力有沒有看到
那這一波很遜
連700元都沒有
下去了 明天如果
因為當沖順勢盤
他狠一點
明天1點之前再殺一波
我可以舉很多例子
1點之前再殺一波
之後 轉折過後
馬上再往上
所以明天國巨
我覺得是再加碼的一次點位
我不知道00981A
會不會看我的節目
說不定他明天可以再加碼
好不好 瑤池金母 衝了啦
衝了啦 人生命一條 怕什麼
衝了 想要當最紅的
而且這麼少胃納量是不是
國巨也衝一下
華新科也衝一下
想要當最紅
主動型ETF就是要衝了啦
不用怕啦 好不好 衝了
我是考慮真的能不能再買
我講話都很直接 好不好
當然有些人是套牢
就像我講的
套牢就是愛情故事一樣
股市就像愛情一樣
有時候套牢不是真愛
只是你不甘心而已
你要分清楚國巨
是你的真愛還是你的不甘心
不甘心你該走就走 是不是
你覺得是真愛
你覺得他看好他會創新
看好他會再創高峰
那你逢低要加碼啊 是
不論是感情事件還是股市
你要不斷的問自己
這是真愛
還是你是不甘心而已
要問清楚自己
跟自己對話
你就知道答案該怎麼做
下一步該怎麼做了
是真愛 那就去追求
不甘心就該放棄
是真愛 怎麼樣
就該逢低買進
不甘心 那你反彈了
差不多了
停損見好就收
停利見好就收
就這麼簡單 OK
所以股市就像愛情一樣
都是一樣 好不好
人生苦短啊 命一條啊
最傻的還是把錢放在定存 是不是
你看我的台灣50
夯不鋃鐺也是賺1000多萬
1300 1400
我懶得算了啦
因為這沒什麼 好不好 來
哲哲謝囉 環球晶今天賺1萬
謝謝大家啦 好不好
衝了 買新興
最近的航運股
等一下我有時間跟大家講 好不好
精材續抱嗎
今天突然噴
昨天的精材算是個大利空
對不起 這笑得有點奸詐
昨天的精材是大利空
今天還給你拉起來
我跟大家講
這準備要噴了
這準備要噴了好不好
準備要噴了嗎
對 準備要噴了
真的準備要噴了好不好
我其實滿喜歡分析師這個行業的
因為我覺得說
大家最終喜歡的還是我的腦袋啦
股票不準
我再怎麼帥你也不會喜歡我啦
好不好 OK嗎 來
精材有說市場過度反應 來
今天這個盤打幾分
我今天這個盤我給它打
大概有80分耶
沒有到低檔
我怎麼買39000的1億台灣50
然後賺1000多萬
你把它當作一個
上帝 老天給你的一個洗禮
好不好 OK 來
想放棄卻不能甘心放手
導播你會唱這首歌嗎
不會
明天唱一下 好不好 OK
來 環球晶在醞釀前高了 好不好
恭喜昨天有買跌停精材的大大
你看每次跌停的時候都隨便你買
環球晶 我們先講環球晶好了
我們先念一下環球晶的簡訊
我順便喝個水
我們看一下環球晶
賺了100%還沒走啦
之前賺170%
環球晶
一根漲停板 兩根漲停板
三根漲停板
今天走勢也不錯
8月18號
今天8月18號
你看 助理啊
這8月18日期都可以寫錯
是禮拜二
助理 Wake up
以後別叫助理
不是 不要亂給人家取名字
助理拜託醒來
日期寫錯了 大家不好意思
8月18號是禮拜二
來 我們看一下
8月18號禮拜二
今天的簡訊你看一下好不好
今天環球晶 今天漲停
一度漲停對不對
恭喜一下 幫我念一下 美女
8月18號星期二早上10點25分
恭喜6488環球晶
開高走高一路急拉
一度攻上漲停
我們買進到現在最高
已經大賺103% 財富翻倍
我持續看好它 手上持股獲利續抱
恭喜大家賺大錢啦
大家都買到了嗎
我跟你講 環球晶你一定可以買到
因為環球晶我常常被人家罵 是
就本來有些人覺得賺錢
然後有些人抱怨說
哲哲你怎麼那麼貪心啊
我為什麼不貪心
你知道嗎 像之前
最近還有一個
有人在節目上批評我
我是不是有截圖 我傳一下
就是造謠說什麼
什麼2018年國巨 世界
我節目停播
我要往網路發展
我當然把我的中視給停掉 是不是
然後說我環球晶
說我那個2021年 2022年
然後航運股很好玩
讓人家賠很多
我說總結起來
最後我記得沒錯的話是賺啊
因為我七進七出
是不是 導播我記得沒錯
一開始有一部分有賠
最後好像賺回來
有印象嗎
有印象對不對
導播也有印象
導播那麼小聲幹什麼 沒錯
真的有印象
我敢講就是有印象
好 就是說都是這樣子
所以常常被人家唸
可是我就是看很遠
就像底下就有留言說
哲哲真的很準
但是他看我的節目
有欣興100多元
跌到什麼 跌到70幾元
我其實很想底下留言
然後說算了
因為可能是以前是會員
然後收到網路的消息
沒有給我續約
我看一下
欣興70幾元是去年的事
今年多少 1145元 沒錯
投資朋友 我選一個飆股
然後他不到一年的時間
他一年多的時間
他可以從70元漲到1145元
漲十幾倍
13倍 14倍
我選股哪邊錯誤
問題是我覺得
你們要的就是
我一定要永遠一買就要漲
常常有這樣的事發生
但不是每次
我能說什麼
當然我覺得他不滿我
我覺得可以接受
因為投資有賺有賠
我告訴大家
如果你們要每天賺的
不好意思 去看詐騙集團
或有些老投顧
每天跟你講賺錢
去看他的節目 不要看我的節目
我沒辦法
可是你跟我說投資的誠信
我第一
我跟你說投資的誠信
你說做人的誠信 我也不差
可是人與人的相處
我不敢說我100分
因為哲哲真的有時候
比較機車一點 比較吹毛求疵
這個我知道
不一定每個人喜歡我
共事的有些人
要嘛就很喜歡我
要嘛有些人就不喜歡我
可是就投資的誠信
我絕對是最認真的
我絕對是最努力的
絕對不會去怎麼樣
去騙大家 這個你不用擔心
也不可能跟主力配合
我也是全台灣投顧業怎麼樣
唯一法院認證
因為之前還有人告我
還我清白啊
還說什麼是不是跟主力掛鉤
還我清白
我是全台灣唯一一個什麼
唯一一個 不好意思
是簽結
我還知道這是簽結
這比不起訴更能證明我的清白
至少兩個檢察官要證明我的清白
全台灣唯一的好不好
這個跟大家講
所以你去想想看
你要怎樣分析師好不好
我找這個不起訴的證明
沒有關係啦
之前我跟大家講過
所以一樣啊
還我清白 證交所還查過喔
還找到偵緝大隊 證交所查過喔
久了你們就知道
什麼叫做清白
什麼叫做最努力的分析師
好不好 我跟大家講
投資的誠信我是很要求自己的 好不好
欣興啊
就是那時候受到網路上的攻擊
有些會員受不了
欣興受不了
現在你自己看
從200塊 有沒有看到
到1000多塊 扯不扯
200塊到1000塊
是不是 不止啦
這是100多塊有沒有看到
200到1000多有沒有看到
200到1000多 自己看
這一段
200 1000多 扯不扯
還不是說週線 這是日線
我是真的很認真要幫大家賺錢
好不好 扯遠了
不要每次大家覺得在抱怨
還是要講一下 來
今天這麼多 嚇死大家好不好
航運三雄很多人
現在應該很多人
清清白白
中美晶都不噴
你不用擔心
中美晶有機會噴 好不好 來
今天有這麼多人 好不好
來 這個跟大家講
還有人就是之前講
摩爾最近有人被告
金管會開罰 獲利保證
要告人很簡單
就去提告就可以告了
被告又怎麼樣
重點是有沒有事
你說有沒有人
金管會開罰或獲利保證
投資朋友 我告訴大家好不好
基本上只要經營金融機關的
很難不被罰 這是事實
但是我們得要虛心接受
好不好 很難不被罰
這沒代表什麼
我覺得主管機關該做他們做的事情
被罰跟刑法上違法
這是兩回事
一個是行政法 好不好
你不要聽有些分析師
或有些網友
根本看了就是同業
把它誇張化
哪一個投顧沒被罰
當然我不能這樣講
就代表我們沒事
只是被罰行政法跟違法
是兩件事
那你去看啊
之前有人說我們有爭議
那最後某個168
他說我們怎麼樣 怎麼樣
網路上只看到168這個事情
然後攻擊我
不知名的報紙攻擊我
那背後是不是某個分析師搞的
你們自己去想 好
這不是重點 重點是
我們有人去銀行領錢
要匯款給我們
銀行行員看到匯款
去亂查網路消息
某一家銀行 我就不講了
某一家銀行去查網路消息
我們這個有糾紛
XX銀行 我就馬上去查那一家
他們的行員
也有偷客戶的錢
還更狠 偷客戶的錢
我去查一下 不只啦
每一家大銀行都有
那些大銀行都不要存錢嗎
你懂嗎
你們去查 你們只要查
比如說去查國泰銀行 富邦銀行
行員拿客戶錢
基本上都有中標 好不好
或者是一些糾紛 都有中標
那就代表他們不行嗎
我也不會這樣講
這樣你懂不懂 要懂邏輯
不要只看片面的新聞好不好
所以我跟你講
投資的誠信我是沒問題 好不好
你說有些行銷的
有些人覺得過度行銷被罰
這個跟投資誠信沒有關係吧
是不是 我又不是故意害大家賠錢
是不是 這才重點嘛
所以要搞清楚這些邏輯
不要受影響
投資誠信我一定OK啦
因為為什麼
我今天看一看我美債又多賠了
我也是覺得當分析師很可憐的
嘴巴賤 愛講說賺2200萬才走
我放個美債
第一次賺1500萬
大家把我當神你知道嗎
第二次又說要賺2200萬
害我現在不能出
還被人家笑
可是說老實話
有美債 到現在美債只有我該賠錢
你們都不該賠錢
不要買美債了 好不好
不好的商品 好不好
現在跌呢 現在跌很慘
為什麼現在跌
我跟你講 我也是一句話
我說話算話
如果現在不當分析師
我第一件事把美債賣掉
換台灣50
我多賺1億 我跟你講
不只 那時候是17000
我很想換耶
我多賺2億多
你們自己算一下
真的不誇張
我跟你講 我真的不誇張
我講的話
你知道網路很變態嗎
我講的每一句話
大家都會記起來
所以這個可以去查
我講的每一句話
哲哲為什麼現在
投資上的誠信沒有出事
多少人 多少同業嫉妒我
可是嫉妒我又幹嘛
又不會增加他們的業績
他們很多人要找我碴
可是我到底哪邊有跟你故意說謊話
都查得出來
而且我一個影片都沒有刪
基本上我不會特別去刪影片
有沒有刪一次
我不敢確定 可能刪一兩支
基本上我不會去特別刪影片
你懂不懂
你去看我每一個影片
好不好 幾千支影片
都可以去留著我的記憶 回憶
好不好 來
我們來看一下 我剛才說到哪邊
我說這個債對不對 對
那個AI巨擘
發債掀排擠效應 為什麼發債
因為我需要錢啊 對不對
我需要錢啊
來 約1.1兆美元年增到30%
近1.5兆美元
我說過了 很多人說現金流轉負
不用現金流轉負啊
他們不能發行公司債喔
是不是 是
那1.1兆到1.5兆怎麼辦
錢就那麼多嘛 怎麼辦
然後美國投資級公司債發行額變高怎麼樣
的情況之下 我問你一件事
那大家會不會
你看Alphabet
30年期公司債近6.4%
我想不出來美國公司債會倒
如果Alphabet 我想不出來
你聽得懂嗎
所以有錢人都是買美國公司債
你知道嗎 是
買那種績優的美國公司債
較同期限的美債高1.15個百分點
有沒有看到
6.4%很誇張耶
好不好 6.4%很誇張有沒有看到
Meta資料中心相關債券
7月殖利率逾7.5%
那請問你啦 誰要買美債啊
那美債怎麼辦
只能跟他拚了啦
利率也要變高了
利率變高 你記得債券公司很簡單
利率跟價格是相反
利率變高怎麼樣 價格下滑
價格下滑以後怎麼樣
又開始有些買盤
你會看到便宜了
這時候資金就會往債市走
往債市走 股市就會資金外流
外流怎麼樣 就是賣掉
就有賣壓了 懂這個邏輯嗎
所以你說這個AI會造成債市的動盪
這是合理的 這樣懂不懂
因為我需要籌資 我需要募資
我越籌資 越募資
我是不是要給人家越多好處 對
我籌越多錢 OK啊
你借100萬跟1000萬
條件不一樣啊 是不是
你借那麼多錢
我怕你會不會倒
你借100萬我覺得你不會倒
借1000萬我覺得你會倒
怎麼辦 我舉例
借1000萬 我當然利息要高一點
吸引我啊
所以Alphabet的公司債
變6.4%
Meta資料中心7.5%
比美債又高了
變成美債也不得不利率變高
美債這個爛東西
我很少這樣講 讓我賠很多
不是潛在的賠1000多萬 好不好
不是1000多萬
是潛在的讓我
因為那個機會成本
我卡在那邊啊 你知道嗎
1.74億的美債
買台灣50賺翻了
你想想看我現在不是買1億
假設我是買3億喔
我會賺 最多賺1500萬嘛
一個禮拜多賺4500萬 天啊
是不是 沒錯吧
你自己算算看吧
是不是1.74億美債
湊一湊 湊個3億
是不是加原本的1億
是不是 湊個3億
好多喔
很多 沒有
可是那時候我要換掉美債
你們都可以作證是17000
來幫我作證一下
所以很多人不了解我
有些同業斷章取義
我真的也沒那麼在乎錢
嘴巴講而已啦
我比較在乎跟你們相處啦
我要是在乎錢喔 怎麼樣
我就第一個 我先怎麼樣
先停播個一個月
不當分析師嘛 再出來就好啦
然後把美債賣掉 是不是
不要當分析師最快
最快嘛 就不當分析師嘛
或是先停止嘛 是不是
再把美債賣掉
也沒騙你們 是不是
就不當分析師
因為我要講要當分析師
我美債沒有賺2200萬就怎麼樣
就不當分析師了 是不是
可是沒關係
我要跟你講就是一個誠信
你們要記得誠信很重要
投資誠信很重要 好不好
要求我投資誠信就好
很多人要求到我什麼
哲哲你會不會煮麵給人家吃
我說關我什麼事
Joeman不要扯到我身上
最近很紅的話題
很紅的話題還扯到我
我投資誠信 你可以要求我
你不要要求我
過馬路一定要扶老奶奶
這樣我很緊張
雖然我看到可能會扶一下
可是有時候沒有看到
這樣懂嗎
投資誠信你絕對可以要求我的
好不好 來
今天直播好多喔
6400 快爆發了
講得好實在
我們現在直播很恐怖耶
你們很多人留言耶
我看不完啦 好不好
真的笑死 美債爛東西
我要變成直播速播了 好不好
國泰科技龍頭可以嗎
我跟你講啦
那麼多ETF你就買台灣50就好
不要那麼多 你懂不懂 好不好
哲哲喜歡吃牛肉麵嗎
我蠻喜歡吃的
好不好 你們不要那個
不要性騷擾我
皮膚看起來好 謝謝大家
我有運動啦 好不好
運動加睡眠 好不好
聯發科 好 不要那麼多
你們現在話很多耶 好恐怖喔
我愛你 力積電還好看嗎
茂達跟力成
力成不錯 好不好
臻鼎500以下是禮物嗎 好不好
哲哲寶貝我愛你
願意4點煮牛肉麵給你吃
每天報到節目一個月了
力積電賠到快脫褲子了
我願意解力積電
但是你不要煮牛肉麵給我吃 謝謝
這樣我很容易胖
你們那麼多人煮牛肉麵給我吃
好不好 來
6770力積電
不要啦 力積電
力積電殺下去嗎 對不對
我想再加碼華邦電 我是認真的
華邦電我想買
那個助理提醒我一下華邦電 好不好
力積電我就跟你講說
股市還是要有故事
群聯也殺下去了
群聯不該殺啦
莫名其妙 真的莫名其妙
記憶體不死啦 好不好
很多人說記憶體 說航運股2.0
我給你一個東西航運股2.0
2603是不是 長榮
你看航運股現在多少
今天238
看起來好像沒有創新高
250對不對
你們冷靜一下好不好
有時候發幾10元的股利
還原好不好
用週線來看 厲不厲害
這邊是2021年 有沒有看到
從200多元殺到6 70元
有沒有看到 有
這邊那時候新高
很多同業為了攻擊我說
彷彿我買在最高點這一天
來來去去 幾進幾出
後來我都反敗為勝
如果沒有記錯的話好不好
來 反敗為勝
你看這邊很高
不好意思 現在在這邊
所以記憶體最差就是這樣子而已
股價就是
人家不願意給他4倍本益比
可是我跟你講
你知道意思嗎
如果他一個景氣循環可以達5年以上
我認為可以超過
那他就像長榮一樣
我再講一件事
這是今天最有感觸的一句話
記憶體最差就是
我不管啦
群聯給你4倍本益比啊
跟長榮一樣
我給你3倍本益比 4倍本益比
那他也跌不下去
他會跌 但是他不會
他跌到差不多的時候
應該說他會跌下去 跌下去的時候
第一個你敢加碼
就算你不加碼也沒關係
他最後會慢慢 還原除權息
扣掉你給的股利
加上你給的股利
人家是一直創新高的有沒有看到
這邊一直創新高有沒有 這週線圖
他可能隔比較久 隔3 4年
我覺得記憶體不會那麼差
因為他畢竟是電子股
電子股大家喜歡的
為什麼 因為他週期一直還在
他最繁榮的週期結束了
但是他一個小週期
一個中長期的週期還在
你懂不懂 那還在
本益比3倍 4倍
你懂不懂
本益比的相反
如果相反的話
他就是殖利率啦 你懂不懂
本益比的相反就是殖利率
這個要跟你們講嗎 來
本益比嘛 股價
教你們數學
除以EPS
就是本益比對不對
是不是 是
相反的把它互換
他就變成殖利率了
如果我們就是
多少EPS我都要發的話 假設啦
好不好 理論上
本益比越低 殖利率越高
懂嗎
聽我講這個邏輯喔
沒有分析師跟你講這一段
今天他可能漲不動
奇怪 118元的EPS
然後2000元不保 群聯啊
那我今年可能賺個400元啊
我大概4倍的本益比
哪有這麼低的本益比
台達電是60倍的本益比
這麼低的本益比代表什麼意思
越低的本益比 我剛才講過了
記起來喔 這一段很重要
越低的本益比
相對來說殖利率比較高
長榮就走這一套啊
本益比給他很低啊
我每天就發股利
發到最後你也賺錢啊
這是最差的情況
我講的是記憶體最差
就是我獲利多少 我不管你
市場就給我4 5倍本益比啊
那是最爛的情況
我講最爛
他還是還原除權息會創新高
那為什麼不賭一把
懂嗎 記憶體相關的可以賭一把
記住我這一段邏輯
這一段邏輯是要經過那種什麼
慘痛的事實
2018年 2022年
2018年國巨事件
然後從200到1200
再從1200再腰斬到200
然後從航運股20塊漲到200多塊
是不是 再從200多塊再對折
這是有感而發的
沒有人跟你講這些東西
你聽不懂 你等一下回去再看重播
這個YouTube可以重播是20次 30次
你知道 所以他有神功護體
你懂不懂
殖利率差你會很生氣
怎麼本益比給那麼低啊
因為我本益比如果4倍
我給個40倍 我股價可以漲10倍
本益比怎麼那麼低啊 莫名其妙
可是就是因為本益比低
以後殖利率會變高
哲哲那個群聯說要研發
那是現在嘛
我講的是一個長期現象嘛
這樣懂不懂 OK嗎
這一段有聽得懂嗎 懂
所以他只要持續個4 5年
那本益比那麼低的話
殖利率會很高
OK 懂我的東西嗎
來 廣達可以嗎 我們看一下
我今天想看一下喔
緯創我們看一下 緯創
創新高後拉回
我有沒有說股票不要追新高
有沒有說不要追 有
有沒有 廣達怎麼看
老AI真的很可憐
沒人疼 沒人愛
那鴻海這個是最誇張
鴻海拉回想再買
可是就是
我還是有點想走啦 我說老實話
鴻海再這樣子我不想理他了好不好
因為市場就不買單嘛
不買單就算了嘛
我們買低基期的好不好
我覺得鴻海你逢低也可以買
但市場喜歡爆發力強的好不好
爆發力強我們看環球晶
先來看一下環球晶
我總要講我的股票
一直講別人的股票幹嘛
航運股我考慮
現在已經列入我的選股範圍內了
先跟你講喔 好不好
那剛才講到發債的效應
也跟你講這個邏輯了好不好
輕鬆 你看看我都隨便舉例
然後讓你懂這些邏輯
剛才那一段很重要喔 來
我們來看一下
對 記憶體看一下
大摩看好舊世代的記憶體漲價潮
大摩有些資料不錯
有些資料還好啦
我覺得這個大摩的不重要
因為所有的外資研究報告是
漲價多少
它不會像我的想像力 是不是
我之前講什麼
託管推論
這一塊你知道嗎
你懂不懂意思
跟人家租晶片
然後幫我生出程式來
然後幫我電源管理
幫我電力管理這些東西 是不是
你只要幫我生出有效的程式
而且AI語音現在很OK
這一塊會再大部分都成長
原來AI變現了
原來講現金流有問題的是這些傻瓜
因為他們沒有想像力
外資大摩 所有的
大部分的分析師
尤其台灣的分析師
尤其外資的分析師
他只會跟你講這些數字
我建立在說這些的想像力上面
以後這些記憶體會需要更多
你懂我的意思嗎 是
所以季增50% 50%
我覺得會更多啦
你不要想太多好不好
這個報告聽聽就好
所以記憶體我很看好好不好 OK
記得要想像力喔 好不好
哲哲的股票會賺錢
就是因為我看得比人家遠
好不好 記得一件事
疫情的時候只有我講
一年內有疫苗
我那時候講的時候還被很多醫生罵
還說要跟我賭
我說沒問題
最後呢 最後哲哲對了
我也不會在乎這些東西
不是啦 我不是瞧不起醫生這個行業
我講是事實
就是我看很遠好不好
而且這個是我的本業
我覺得AI這個一定沒問題 好不好
你們現在有看到什麼機器人
還比賽100公尺跑
大陸的機器人很恐怖 跑12秒
然後可以跳什麼10幾公尺
好恐怖 越來越像人了你知道嗎
真的很恐怖啦
我覺得以後真的會
真的機器人可以出來 好啦
我講這個東西
我們先講崇越的法說
崇越的法說算是
代理商 OK嗎
來 矽晶圓產業前景
全面復甦好不好
那因為它有法說嘛
法說裡面我只要看重點就好
跟我有關係的
所以你看這行業也是一樣
你可以看它上中下游行業
這就是上游行業
通路商 有沒有看到
通路大廠 材料通路大廠
你看它這邊是不是有材料
它的材料也賣很多
我賣 我可能賣其他的
什麼石英布或怎麼樣
我只要聽它的矽晶圓就好
因為那些不是我要的股票 對
可是我只要聽半導體通路大廠
我就聽到它講的 你看到
它說市場真的很熱絡有沒有看到
矽晶圓市場真的很熱絡
所以請問你
你看它說市場真的很熱絡
你不要聽公司派講嘛
你要聽別人講嘛
所以今天為什麼
環球晶今天拉起來
我就跟你講了
等到環球晶EPS都算出來了
它股價早就3 4000塊了啦
3 4000塊有點誇張啦
我先講2500好不好
不是不可能喔
只是我不想畫那麼大餅而已
現在啦 好不好 來
曾海華說這個市場真的很熱絡
有沒有看到
直接講矽晶圓有沒有看到
然後因為晶圓代工廠
跟記憶體的稼動率
處於95%到90%有沒有看到
所以它講到 是不是我講的邏輯
矽晶圓需要什麼
矽晶圓的客戶是誰
先進晶圓代工廠還有記憶體
晶圓代工廠 台積電
甚至成熟製程的代工廠也需要啊
成熟製程的也需要啊
世界先進 有沒有看到
還有記憶體稼動率
那我問你記憶體要擴廠
現在就很需要
然後記憶體越擴廠呢 怎麼樣
越需要矽晶圓
上游矽晶圓很缺 你看
今年出貨數量來看
今年矽晶圓成長幅度
可達雙位數有沒有看到
你看成熟製程也開始回升有沒有看到
所以先進製程成長
成熟製程成長
還有什麼 記憶體還成長還擴廠
有沒有
所以我跟你講
矽晶圓是台灣少數
你要買欣興1000多塊的嗎
1000多塊你是少數的
少數的漲不多的股票
族群還沒有漲很多 是
中美晶很多人問
你還不開心 趕快買啊
只是你要買矽晶圓這一塊
因為中美晶也有太陽能那一塊
那你要買純矽晶圓那一塊
一定是環球晶漲比較凶 好不好
所以我們這個圖也做了 來給你看
來 這是AI圖
HBM引爆晶圓用量放大效果
矽晶圓這一塊
傳統的DRAM就這樣子有沒有看到
一般拔電腦就看得到
拔電腦 拆除筆電
HBM是這樣子堆疊有沒有看到
是不是 是
看起來不佔空間
但其實更需要啊 對
它本來從平面的感覺
變成立體的感覺
體積更大一點 體積更大啊
整個用數量那很多啊
重點是他們現在都還沒擴廠成功喔
你要擴廠要一兩年
我真的沒辦法想像一兩年後
然後記憶體開始擴廠成功
到底矽晶圓會多缺
哲哲  怎麼辦
你記得我這一段
我這個是重播是要一年後看的
一年後看 好不好
那時候環球晶已經漲上去了
你早就買不到了
所以你幹嘛想那麼多
所以國巨今天跌下去OK啊
他強任他強 清風拂山崗
來 你記得一件事
請問你為什麼我的1億台灣50
一下子就賺1000萬
一天多的時間沒錯吧
現在1000多萬了
一下子賺1000萬
隔天又漲停板
因為跌深啊
你們已經忘記哲哲跌深了是不是
好了傷疤忘了痛
散戶的問題 散戶最大的問題
你不要有這種問題啊
你資金是散戶
但是你思維要像大戶
怕什麼 拉回就買
你看今天矽晶圓是怎樣
今天還是很便宜
環球晶又怎麼樣
前陣子1600 一堆人都敢買
1060不敢買
是不是 拚了啦
人生就命一條 拚了啦
哲哲用生命來支撐你
投資的誠信
沒關係 你可以來考核我
中美晶怎麼看
你要想一件事 不用怎麼看
什麼叫不用怎麼看
今天矽晶圓
今天環球晶這樣拉起來
明天再噴出去
我怕你買不到200元以下的中美晶
你現在能買到200元以下的中美晶
你要很開心 好不好
平常心就好
你要買到600元以下的國巨
你要開心 平常心就好
又不是每天噴噴噴
每天噴你受得了
你說 剛才有人留言說哲哲
我那個凌晨4點幫我煮牛肉麵
OK啊 你可以每天嗎
當然不行嘛 對不對
應該沒辦法
翻臉了 我跟你講
這一樣啊 股票也不可能每天噴啊
也不會每天跌啊
也會翻臉啊 是不是
都是一樣 平常心就好
OK嗎 好不好 好
來 導播怎麼那麼小聲
你看人家講得那麼小聲
來 有了哲哲忘記舊情人
南亞科算假突破嗎
南亞科 因為大戶在裡面嘛
我覺得會 他有可能假突破
南亞科的大戶
好像跟金居的大戶是同一個
當然我講出去以後我怕
他就會不一樣嘛
因為有錢可以做很多事情
你看金居的手法
各位你看金居的手法
那一陣子在那個
300元的時候有沒有看到
只要突破有沒有看到 是
都會故意有點假突破有沒有看到
然後拉回去 假突破拉回去
一次比一次高
所以這個作價很厲害
一次比一次高對不對 沒錯吧
這沒錯吧 有沒有看到
是不是
因為那時候300元有壓力有沒有看到
沒錯吧
那大戶很厲害有沒有看到
據說同一批大戶
拉起來創新高
給你越來越高有沒有看到
越來越高
每次有機會 最後慢慢殺下來
可是殺下來以後怎麼樣
這一陣子又拉到
又758 又殺下去了
我覺得他手法有點像這邊
說錯了 4次有沒有看到
都快到300元的時候
300元有壓力有沒有看到
前低也故意讓你不要破很低
他會看線型喔
他知道你不喜歡看線型破掉
他就不會讓你破
他知道你喜歡看創新高的股票
創新高給你看
創新高的時候再出一點點
出一點點給大家
可是不錯啦
至少好主力嘛
至少大家也賺到嘛
創新高的股票哪有不好 是不是
我說手法是這樣子
當然那是金居跟南亞科的手法
可是我還是要強調一件事
不代表一樣 為什麼
因為記憶體實在基本面很好
卡在籌碼亂而已
這樣懂嗎 好不好 OK嗎
你看我教大家很多東西 好不好
明天機器人展
對機器人股有什麼影響
以前會正面影響
現在我覺得還好 好不好
對 我要改變我的說法
我以前說機器人概念股是假的
我覺得機器人概念
今年就是假的
因為我覺得機器人不會那麼快
廣達也這樣講
我覺得5年內有可能
就是初步模型 好不好
中美晶閉眼買嗎 睜一半好不好
睜一半 一半 一半 好不好
哲哲越看越年輕
有在運動 平常心好不好 OK
心情好 就跟你講嘛
減少自己的壓力
然後做自己想做的事情
開心就錄 不開心就不錄
是不是 就這麼簡單
當然我還是喜歡錄
我不喜歡完全不錄
就是不會把自己
以前壓力給自己到200%
我想要跟大家長長久久 OK嗎
然後有時候講個幹話 開開心心 OK嗎
來 破7000人了
有講載板嗎 有
剛才講ABF
那現在幾分了
41了 我們再講一些股票 來
今天講很多手法
還有講一些記憶體
還有講說 記憶體有講到兩個行業
一個是航運股
跟記憶體
然後講低本益比的好處 它是好處
只是缺點就是要很久才發酵 好不好
然後我們看一下台積電
我早就說過換台積電
真的台積電你現在一半嘛
你看台積電是不是要死不活了
因為離前高
台灣股市是不是說
我是不是說48000會有壓力 對
這邊是在48000附近
不是都講過了
你台積電放著幹嘛
當然如果你是長期要放20年
那沒有關係啦 好不好
帆宣我們看一下
帆宣的問題就是
沒有什麼漲也沒什麼跌
我比較喜歡精材
精材今天很精彩 好不好
為什麼 昨天跌停板
今天給你拉到漲停板
代表精材裡面大戶沒有落跑
他就是要告訴你說
這一檔股票由我照 裡面的大戶
有力 好不好
那也代表它基本面OK
它是少數台積電資本支出概念股
少數還漲不多的股票 來
我們念一下我們精材的一個簡訊
來看一下 好
在念之前我再講一次
逆轉188專案
明天就截止了
不要再問我了 好不好
我們恭喜 來
8月18號星期二早上10點30分
恭喜3374精材
開高走高一路急拉 一度攻上漲停
我們買進到現在
最高已經大賺65%
我持續看好它 手上持股獲利續抱
恭喜大家都賺大錢啦
賺65% 有沒有看到
精材啊 是不是
Show time 好戲登場
很精彩的好戲
賺65% 精材這個
真的我說老實話
我本來是想說250
我在考慮要不要買
看起來這個250機率極低
那是不是應該買
因為要不是這個法說的利空
是不是應該買 是
所以一堆股票要買
你為什麼要放在台積電
那種沒什麼漲的股票
沒什麼跌的股票反而不好
我現在反而喜歡跌很深的股票
等到台灣股市5萬點
等到越來越多消息發現現金流轉正
越來越多消息發現
記得一件事 會轉正
我認為轉正的機率很高
第二個 變現率很高
就是AI可以馬上賺錢
因為你們不知道它進步的幅度
跟網路速度差太多了
你懂不懂 以前是網路.COM
一個.COM公司沒賺錢了
然後就可以直接怎麼樣
本益比100倍以上
或者沒賺錢的
就直接股價漲多少%
沒賺錢不可能本益比100倍
就是賺一點點錢
本益比100倍以上
這些都獨家告訴大家 好不好
導播現在幾分了 40幾
44了 來
你們現在好多人 看一下
洗版
還有人說哲哲
你們有沒有買那個假的 那個什麼
假的什麼機器人
就是幫我們留言
我快笑死人了
全台灣我最紅 還需要買嗎
Lily你不覺得這個很好笑嗎 不用啦
那個一看就知道同業在講的話 是
100多萬
我能買到100多萬也算厲害啦
你說有沒有打廣告 有啦
可是我不需要去買假留言 來
7311人 來
很多人
哲哲寶貝 你們一直叫我寶貝
信昌電我看一下
叫我寶貝我無轍
信昌電也不錯
信昌電 禾伸堂
既生巨禾伸堂
華新科一起
就看國巨就好了 好不好
解一起好不好
它是一起的好不好
可以看微星跟世界 來看一下
微星真的是不應該這樣跌
好不容易創新高
不應該這樣跌
可是我真的覺得微星再跌下去
你可以買一點點
我比較想要買是跌比較深的
比如說國巨
我本來想買 你聽得懂嗎
精材再跌我想買
或是這邊跌一下我想買
就是跌深的比追高好
追高再拉回也不錯
但是我問你
它拉回是有跌幾%
你這個頂多差不多10幾%而已
可是你看國巨
它還是跌了多少
跌了60%
沒有錯吧 60% 40%
差不多 跌50%
也50%多啦 好不好
50幾% 有沒有看到
它還是跌50幾%
從1220 一半就是610是不是 是
所以它比610還少
這邊比610還少
它是跌了50幾%
跌50幾%還是可以買
你知道為什麼
今年哲哲的績效特別好
盡量不追高 開心就好
來 我說真的
助理提醒我
明天我要買股票
我要買跌深的股票
是哪一檔我不跟大家講 好不好
這個股票跟大家講
世界先進也是不錯
這個沒關係
打第二隻腳最好
中小型股打第二隻腳最好 好不好
現在麻煩的是
我看起來世界先進也很甜
我看起來國巨也很甜
精材也很甜
環球晶也很甜 好不好
然後又有航運股開始創新高的
好像也不錯
很多很甜的股票
跌深的股票很甜
我現在煩惱的是
太多股票可以買
我不煩惱沒有股票可以買
你懂不懂
逆轉188專案
我趕快來找大家 好不好
不是 大家趕快來找我
我不找大家 我很忙
明天要截止
我最後看大家有沒有什麼問題
好不好 來
結算日有什麼影響 剛才講了
你們今天怎麼那麼多人
今天大家很愛問問題
感覺都新網友是不是
大家新網友要記得一件事
我有看過 我之前2024年也是一樣
一根長黑K
跌了4000點 5000點買最低
那時候我也是直播人數
點閱率也是幾十萬
後來又下滑了
新網友 大家要記得一件事好不好
投資沒有永遠的賺
理論上也不會一直賠 好不好
就是投資有賺有賠
不要對哲哲有過高的期望
你可以要求我過高的投資誠信
沒關係 好不好
過高的期望不要想太多
我現在很順不代表以後很順
我明明已經可以大收會員了
哪有一個分析師在講
在收會員的時候講這個話
可是我也告訴大家
因為我希望大家跟我是長長久久
長久以後你會發現
我的績效真的不錯
你看很短 哲哲那麼短嗎
哲哲有看起來
不要扯遠了
就是沒有那麼短
我們沒有看那麼短
懂不懂 好不好
平常心
平常心以後你反而比較愛我
好不好 OK嗎
今天好多留言 好不好
我知道你還有錢
什麼都想買 好不好
大家愛你 好不好
所以要結束了 好不好
而且不要股市跌才想到哲神
也不要最近很熱 行情很熱
哲哲是愛情大師 開始愛我
長久一點 好不好
傷心寶貝 哲哲寶貝
你們都刷一排哲哲寶貝
鴻海我剛才有講了
你叫我寶貝 嘴巴說的而已
我們剛講而已 好不好
哲哲寶貝
哲哲我沒錢了
我說我看起來有那麼短嗎
是疑問詞 好不好
緯創怎麼了我剛剛講了
不要來鬧
台指期明天壓低結算
有可能 好不好
不去預設 它就是當沖順勢盤
就是一路走高 一路走低
1點之前 再講一次
明天就是一路走高
要嘛一路走低 懂不懂
你明天9點半就知道
會走高還走低了 好不好
為什麼
你看它一路走低的時候
你是在這邊就知道會再繼續往下
你懂嗎 懂
一路走低
是不是在這邊就知道會一路往下
這個時候再做空就好了
所以這是結論
要結束了 現在幾分
49 趕快結束了 好不好
趕快 我真的 我開心這個
大盤沒有打第二隻腳
但是有些個股打第二隻腳
我很開心
這個腳是長短腳
我認為不會破前低
破前低的機率很低
如果大家運氣那麼好的話
還破前低 太好了
破前低的機率很低
所以趕快趁差不多的時候
有點長短腳的時候進場
國巨開始小回檔的時候進場
或是 環球晶沒有
或中美晶有些股票
稍微回檔的時候進場
去想想看你要怎麼的分析師
逆轉188專案
明天截止
最近直播人數好多
點閱率好高
你去想想看最紅的分析師是誰
歡迎來電洽詢080668085
或者加我LINE私訊我
記得哲哲不論對或錯
一切的一切預告在前面
逆轉188優惠專案
明天就截止 明天晚上就截止
也預祝各位能夠賺大錢
Byebye